eine kleine überraschung vor einem monat
hat es möglich gemacht
kulturschaffende mitten im nationalrat
eine ausnahme die zur regel werden
sollte
35 kulturschaffende haben letzten
sonntag für den nationalrat kandidiert
schauspieler musiker autoren und
regisseure auf der liste kunst und
politik
die schriftstellerin ruth schweikert hat
die liste mit initiiert
doch von wahlkampf keine spur
die woche vor den wahlen verbringt sie
an der frankfurter buchmesse ist ihre
kandidatur für den nationalrat nur
symbolisch die liste am ende nur eine
kunstaktion es ist es bekenntnis zu der
schweizerische demokratie nie und dazu
auch noch die politischen landschaft mit
zu gestalten braucht es da für
kulturschaffende im parlament reicht es
nicht wenn sie sich mit vollem einsatz
durch ihre kunst engagieren
die schauspielerin mona petri hat
ebenfalls für den nationalrat kandidiert
sie sieht in der aktion keinen
widerspruch grund kann muss aber nicht
politisch für beides platin ist es
extrem wichtig es ist auch ein luxus
geprüftes mal recht viel zeit hat sich
mit sache beschäftigen und das video ads
bringen konkret politischen rechte für
die kunden wo er unter beamten schon
früher ließen sich kulturschaffende im
bundeshaus blicken der künstler max bill
ende der 60er jahre als nationalrat oder
adolf muschg er kandidierte 1975 als
ständerat für die sp und max frisch
sowie friedrich dürrenmatt gelten heute
als prototypen politisch engagierter
kulturschaffender er hatte schnell genug
nach gut zwei jahren als präsident der
sp olten gab der schriftsteller und wird
alex capus sein amt wieder ab vom
künstler zum politiker für ihn ein
schwieriger rollenwechsel politik redet
sich doch immer konsens finden die
kompromissfindung und eigentlich könnten
sie ist gerne teil das ist konzentration
auf zack sein wird und suche nach der
möglichkeit den unverwechselbaren stimme
nur um sie dem club schon zwei
temperament fragt was eigentlich nie
wieder sprechen und uns schließen
freigeister im nationalrat wäre doch mal
was anderes als immer nur juristen
bauern und unternehmer
mit dieser idee hat sich auch ein
jazzmusiker letzten sonntag zur wahl
gestellt wo so viele verschiedene kräfte
da es in der stimme drehen für einige
wohl kompromissbereit
stefan zweifel mein kollege auf der
liste seit das stroh im monat verloren
und uns uns glauben aus unmöglicher dass
das immer wieder eingang findet politik
und damit auch gesellschaft der glaube
an das unmögliche hat am wahlsonntag
keine berge versetzt kein
nationalratssitz für kunst und politik
auch nicht für amri ziegele
wann sind sie skeptisch klar die sitze
gingen an andere
jetzt müssen die kandidaten von kunst
und politik hoffen dass ihre anliegen im
nationalrat nicht untergehen
künstlerische freiheit die kulturelle
vielfalt aber auch die stärkung von
völkerrecht und sozialer gerechtigkeit
gerade mal 0 5 prozent haben ihre liste
gewählt
ruth schweikert sieht in der aktion aber
trotzdem einen erfolg
künstlerin
serie über sieben tages anzeiger
produziert haben als die
schriftstellerinnen und schriftsteller
es gibt künstlerinnen und künstler wo
sich auch als politisch verstand sexier
arbeit oder sechs aber auch indem sie
für dieses mandat quasi der sich
bewerben vier jahre lang haben sie nun
zeit einen kreativen wahlkampf zu planen
denn etwas fantasievoller dürfte sie
durchaus sein
die schweizer politik